Let's take a break from our project for
a bit and talk about a very specific,
but useful feature of
the Google Maps APIs.
>> Here at Google, we have offices all
over the world, from New York to London,
to India, to China, to Sidney.
Just yesterday, I scheduled
a meeting with my teammate in Japan.
>> What if you wanted
a quick way to find out what
time zone you're in
based on the location?
>> That would be really useful.
Luckily, the Google Maps APIs
includes a Time Zone API web service.
This feature is pretty simple,
you can pass in a location in the form
of a lat-long and a day time stamp,
which tells a service whether or
not to adjust for daylight savings, and
the service will give you back a time
zone based on that coordinate.
It'll also tell you whether or not
that time zone is currently offset due
to daylight savings time and
the offset of that time zone from UTC,
which stands for
Coordinated Universal Time.
Don't ask me why it's UTC and CUT,
maybe they didn't want to name it cut.
Let's do a quick example
of the Time Zone API.
I'm going to make a quick
Time Zone API request.
Notice the same name space again.
I'm going to request
the response in JSON format, and
I'm going to make the request for
this specific lat-long.
I'm passing in the time stamp in seconds
which you can usually find converters
online for, or a new code, you can
use the JavaScript date.now function,
and I'm passing in my API key.
Turns out,
this is in Japan standard time.
We see that there's currently no
offset for daylight savings time here,
and that the offset from UTC is
32,400 seconds, which is 9 hours.
Yeah, totally just did that in my head.
Incidentally, this location is
actually to Shiro-jima in Japan,
better known as Cat Island,
where there are more cats than humans.
Let's take a quiz meow.